- All right, before we say goodbye,
we have time for one more story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
The pandemic was hard on
everyone, especially teenage boys.
That's according to Chicago-based
clinical psychologist,
Dr. John Duffy.
But he also says there's hope,
which he writes about in his new book,
"Rescuing Our Sons: 8
Solutions to Our Crisis
of Disaffected Teen Boys."
Dr. Duffy is dialed in right now.
He watches on NBC Chicago.
What's up, Dr. Duffy?
(audience clapping)
- Hi Kelly, how are you?
- I'm so good.
Thank you for joining us.
So, what changes have you noticed?
- Okay, so since the pandemic,
teenage boys are telling me they are sad,
they're really quite lonely,
and they're disconnected from themselves
and from their emotions.
They don't really understand
their emotions very well
'cause we haven't taught them to do that.
They don't understand the emotions
of the people around them.
We know they're disconnected
from us as parents
'cause they're up in that
room with the door closed
or down in the basement
playing video games, right?
And they're also
disconnected from their peers
because they really don't
have the great language
to speak to them.
They talk via Snapchat
or video games with them.
So, the rich discussions
we want them to have,
they don't really have and
they don't really feel worthy
of those good relationships.
All this funnels into
a sense of hopelessness
that has me concerned about
our teenage boys right now.
- Yeah, and what will
happen as they grow older
if they don't have those skills.
So, what do you recommend for parents?
- Yeah, so what parents tend to do
is focus on those things
like the behaviors
that our boys engage in that
don't work for them, right?
If I could only get them to do X and Y
through a series of
punishments and consequences,
then everything would be fine.
I want parents to abandon that for now
and focus on your relationship with them
and the emotional bank
account that you have
in that relationship and light up for them
when you see them.
This is super important
because so many boys tell me nobody ever
through the course of a day, month, year,
lights up for them at all.
So, use that emotional bank account,
watch what he's watching, listen
to what he's listening to.
You can provide a counterpoint
to some of the negative vitriolic stuff
he's hearing on podcasts, on video games,
through YouTube videos.
It is a win-win-win for parenting, Kelly.
Who wouldn't wanna be a part of that?
- Yeah, be involved is really,
is really what it sounds like.
Well, "Rescuing Our Sons:
8 Solutions to Our Crisis
of Disaffected Teen Boys" is out now
and everyone is going home with a copy.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much, Dr. Duffy.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
- [Dr. Duffy] Thank you, Kelly.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
appreciate the work that you're doing.
We mentioned the National
Alliance on Mental Illness
in the last segment, so on your behalf,
Pilot will be writing
them a check for $1,000.
(audience cheering)
- Fantastic, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Duffy.
And thank you to all our guests this hour:
Dan Levy, Coral Pena,
Gesine Bullock-Prado,
Wynonna Judd, and Trisha Yearwood.